[Music]
the modus operandi and deep learning has
been building bigger and larger models
on larger amounts of data and these
models are incredibly over parameterised
the lottery ticket hypothesis is one of
the most exciting ideas in deep learning
this one the best paper award at AI CLR
2019 by providing a massive step in the
direction of training neural networks
with less computing power making deep
learning more accessible and
environment-friendly today we are
talking to Jonathan Franco Jonathan made
waves in the machine learning community
last year when he released his lottery
ticket hypothesis Connor and Yannick and
I who are so excited about the paper
that we've all made videos about it on
our respective channels deep learning
has been mainly the field of scaling up
building more and more parameters and
more and more layers into neural
networks but another field pruning has
been doing the exact opposite we take
these giant networks and we compress
them down after we've trained them the
lottery ticket at offices and its
surrounding body of work it's so
interesting because it states that these
pruned networks are already present at
the beginning of training and if we
could only tell which ones they are
we wouldn't need the entire rest so this
has been an absolutely fascinating topic
for me and I'm absolutely excited that
we can explore this today Jonathan is a
part-time researcher at fair where he's
been working on the early phase of
neural network training which is going
to be published in IEEE clear this year
and he's also been working on training
batch norm and batch norm only which has
been accepted as an oral and Europe's
this year and has also been submitted to
ICML Jonathan is on the OECD network of
experts to discuss AI principles and the
measure of AI progress in OECD countries
he's an adjunct professor of law at the
Georgetown University Law Center he was
a student researcher on the Google brain
team in Cambridge Massachusetts he's a
member of the can
suta Science Advisory Council at
Princeton University and he also
interned at Microsoft in Redmond
he's currently completing his PhD at MIT
focusing on his work around the lottery
ticket hypothesis he's completed a
bachelor's and a master's in computer
science from Princeton University
focusing on cryptography and distributed
computation this week we reached out to
the machine learning reddit we wanted to
hear your questions and so many of you
responded and we have nearly a hundred
upvotes which is incredible we asked
many of your questions to Jonathan so
please stay tuned to hear your questions
answered by the man himself the lottery
ticket hypothesis demonstrated that with
a tiny fraction of the amount of
connections in your network you could
retrain given the same initialization
and you could get even better accuracy
on the test set this was incredibly
intriguing it seemed to tease that the
only reason that we needed these huge
over parametrized networks was because
they were a bit like lumps of clay they
contained a combinatorial explosion of
possible sub networks and we needed to
have all of those different combinations
for SGD to find the relevant sub network
that would provide a useful inductive
prior for our problem in in the original
lottery ticket hypothesis it was only
trained on data sets like safar 10 & M
lists on fairly small architectures it
wasn't trained on the image nets of this
world on things like vgg and ResNet
jonathan has now done some really
interesting work to demonstrate that the
reason it doesn't scale is because of
the instability in the earlier phase of
training and that instability is caused
by stochastic gradient descent it has
this kind of noise associated with it
because it's taking random samples and
feeding it to the training process out
of order but even the larger
architectures they stabilize very
quickly so the take-home message here is
that if you train for a little bit
longer before you start pruning then you
can find winning tickets that still
scale up to these larger architectures
since the original lottery ticket
hypothesis paper Jonathan and his
collaborators have continued the pursuit
of understanding sparse networks prune
neural networks and lottery tickets
recently publishing some incredibly
exciting papers linear mode connectivity
introduces instability to predict the
training success of a lottery ticket sub
network this is a huge step towards
sparse networks from scratch and
reducing the computational cost of
training deep neural networks
stabilizing the lottery ticket
hypothesis uses the stability analysis
to provide insight into how early these
massive neural networks can be pruned to
find the lottery ticket in addition to
stability analysis Frankel has worked on
the early phase of neural network
training describing behavior of weights
at different steps of training such as
the behavior of gradient magnitudes and
when rewinding becomes effective
rewinding this idea of resetting weights
to their value at a previous training
step rather than completely -
initialization was further explored and
comparing rewinding and fine-tuning and
neural network routing in this paper
they make a surprising discovery and you
can keep the same weight after pruning
and only rewind the learning rate
jonathan is also collaborated on an
exhaustive survey of pruning itself they
survey 81 papers and take proving apart
along dimensions of pruning individual
or groups of weights scoring metrics
used to prove scheduling and fine-tuning
after critical networks Frankel has also
collaborated on a fairly surprising
paper titled trading batch norm and only
batch norm on the expressive power of
random features and CNN's
many of us forget that batch norm has
trainable scale and ship parameters in
this study they showed training only
those parameters can reach 83 percent
accuracy on C part n within 866 layer
resna also joining us today is dr.
matthew sal varus matthew is a deep
learning scientist at iRobot
he was a principal data scientist lead
at Microsoft for the last four years and
that's where I met him he was studying
cognitive neuroscience at UCL and he has
a master's a PhD and a postdoc in
computer science from the University of
Essex his specialism was in brain
computer interfaces it was an incredible
opportunity to talk to Jonathan
remember to Like comment and subscribe
and we will see you back here next week
oh and we are here this is the
machine-learning Street Talk YouTube
channel and we have Jonathan Frankel
from MIT and Jonathan is absolutely
famous because his paper called the
lottery ticket hypothesis yeah it just
got an incredible amount of traction in
the community and I think it was so
inspiring for many of us actually all of
us on our respective YouTube channels
have done a video on the lottery ticket
hypothesis and it raises so many
fascinating questions it's almost like
we're looking for a useful inductive
prior and deep learning and with these
densely connected neural networks it's
almost like we're throwing everything
and but the kitchen sink has a problem
we have this big block of clay and we're
kind of chipping away at the clay using
stochastic gradient descent until we
find one of these sub networks that
seems to resonate with the algorithm but
when we do find this sub Network it
seems to be a good inductive prior it
trains better and generalizes better but
with some caveats so I think we've
discovered recently that it doesn't work
say on imagenet and on some of the more
complex architectures go ahead Jonathan
there that's correct so far so the what
would you like me to chat a little bit
about the scaling question in particular
or just talk about the big idea what's
well maybe maybe first maybe first just
some some some person in the cave
somewhere might not have heard about the
big idea so if you just give your talk
your particular talk on the big idea or
your particular take on it that would be
actually also interesting for everyone
right perfect
so we we know that neural networks are
gigantic and in fact we we know that we
can make them smaller after we train
them this isn't something new this is
something that we've known since the
1980s since before I was born probably
since before anybody who's on this
podcast was born so this is old news I
didn't invent pruning or anything like
that and all you do is you take a
network and you train it and then you
remove a bunch of parts train it a
little bit more and you find that you
get about the same accuracy which is
surprising it's
you know I wouldn't have intuitively
thought that but the lesson you take
away from that is that whatever function
you learned whatever you were trying to
learn with this model it had a
representation that was relatively small
in fact it could have fit in a much
smaller Network than the one you started
with so we know that know the lottery
ticket hypothesis question the really
the motivating question here is you know
we know the representation could have
been smaller could the could the network
we train from the beginning have been
smaller this is the animating question
for this entire line of work and if you
won naive thing you might ask is well
I've got the smaller architecture that I
got after training what if I just tried
training using that from the beginning
and this doesn't work very well this is
you know this is no better than you know
just kind of randomly printing the
network than doing a lot of things that
don't work very well and so there's this
lingering question in the literature on
pruning you know why is it that you
can't train these smaller networks from
the start maybe the learning process
actually just requires more capacity
maybe there's something harder about
learning a problem then there is about
actually representing whatever you've
learned in the end and this intuitively
makes sense when I think about learning
calculus that was really hard that took
a lot of work when I think about
recalling the knowledge that I've
synthesized about calculus you know it's
not so hard anymore
it doesn't require as much brainpower
and so maybe that was true for neural
networks and the lottery ticket idea was
that maybe these smaller networks can
train from the beginning but maybe it's
all about the lucky initialization that
we gave to these sub networks so when we
when we create a neural network from
scratch we randomly initialize all the
connections and perhaps this smaller
architecture you got from pruning could
learn from the beginning it was just
that you know you needed to it needed to
get a lucky initialization it got some
good initialization at the beginning
that allowed it to learn from scratch
and so maybe the entire initialization
process is just a giant lottery where
sampling sub-networks hoping that one of
these happens to get lucky that ends up
being what drives the optimization
process and then in the end you know we
could we could prune down to this
network we could have taken it back to
the beginning we could train it again
and it would work just as well so you
know this is a pretty big claim this is
rather ambitious this is you know rather
controversial and the only way that you
can support this is with evidence
so the evidence was you know taking
these networks training them to
completion pruning them and then asking
me question could I have trained this
Prue network from the beginning with the
same initialization trying it and so in
the original paper I try this a bunch of
times and a lot of small networks and it
worked and you know boom I had a cool
paper and a cool hypothesis I'm really
excited about this idea of the sparse
networks from scratch and can you tell
us more about the linear mode
connectivity and how that might get us
closer to being able to prune this
quicker without having to fully train
these deep networks definitely so the
linear mode connectivity I need to take
a step back to explain that idea so the
lottery ticket hypothesis the original
experiment I just described where you
you know you Pru to network you go back
to the beginning and see if it'll still
train this doesn't seem to work on
larger scale networks and you know this
is something we figured out at the end
of the original paper a bunch of other
people pointed out afterwards they tried
to scale this up and that was kind of
disappointing you know it may be this
idea only applies to small networks
maybe you know this isn't this doesn't
explain neural networks in general the
hypothesis is wrong all that good stuff
and so we took a step back and we asked
you know why might this be going on what
what might be driving the lottery ticket
properties to work and what might be
causing them to fail and we figured out
that on large scale networks if we go
almost all the way back to the beginning
but not all the way just almost all the
way then things work again so there's a
small sub network that would train from
early in training and now you have this
great scientific set up it you know it
seems like a disappointment but it
actually became an opportunity we we can
ask if you go back just a little further
things don't work if you go back just a
little later things do work what changed
what's different here it's a it's a
natural experiment and the answer ended
up being what we're calling instability
and the question of instability is kind
of how how consistent is the result of
training a neural network if you change
the the sample of SGD noise stochastic
gradient descent is a noisy process it's
stochastic that's why they call it STD
and so the question was well what is the
effect of the stochasticity on the
outcome of train
and what we ended up finding was that if
you can take the same lottery ticket
network and it always trans to about the
same place it always trans to about the
same optimum it trains to high accuracy
it trains really well it's as good as
the original network if it doesn't train
to the same optimum it seems to be worse
it seems to kind of be you know it gets
taken over by the by the chaos of SGD
noise and our hypothesis is that these
smaller networks are just more likely to
get stuck somewhere so if it's if it's
inconsistent in where it ends up it'll
probably get stuck somewhere most of the
time whereas if it's consistent for some
reason it seems to follow a good
trajectory and end up in a good part of
the optimization landscape maybe even
this the same part that the full network
ended up in although we don't currently
have evidence to support that fact it
would be cool if we could find that out
so do you see there a connection between
the difficulty of the problem and let's
say how much instability you have
because it seems on easy problems like M
nest or C 410 already the sub network at
the very beginning is already stable so
to say right but then with imagenet it
seems like you have to train for a bit
until the sub network becomes stable you
do you think there's a connection to the
to the difficulty of the problem and if
oh I'll let you answer that first so
it's a tricky instability as a tricky
complicated property that we're still
sorting out instability seems to be very
predictive for these lottery tickets sub
networks but it and we we've also looked
at instability on just standard neural
networks and we find that most networks
are unstable at the beginning we in fact
all the networks we've looked at down to
pretty simple tasks are unstable at the
beginning and become stable pretty early
in training which is interesting it
means that you know after a couple
percent of the way into training the
outcome of optimization is basically
determined an SGD noise isn't really
changing your trajectory at all no or at
least different samples of noise aren't
maybe the noise is having some other
beneficial property people hypothesize
that has something to do with
generalization but in terms of actually
changing where you end up it doesn't
seem to make a difference but it doesn't
really have anything to do with accuracy
we think on these dense networks we at
least you know these dense networks are
training to full performance and
you know they seem to be unstable at the
beginning however for the sparse
networks instability seems to make a big
difference which I think highlights the
possibility that these sparse networks
are getting stuck somewhere along the
way unless they have this good property
these sparse networks are just much more
prone to getting trapped in some local
minimums somewhere along the way and
can't get to the good minimum at the end
its instability related to
generalization so what you're saying is
that is essentially the take-home
message of the linear mode paper is that
you should only start pruning when
stability is achieved but what is
stability is instability and about
having local generalization to different
samples of data because that's what SGD
is it's giving different samples of data
and when you reach a level of maturity
and training where stability is reached
then all of a sudden it's resistant to
that noise so I wouldn't say resistant
to that noise it's the it's a it's a
subtle property where the the outcome of
optimization will remain the same
regardless of the sample of noise but if
you were to change the distribution of
noise if you were to increase the batch
size or change the learning rate
something that would change the
distribution of noise I'm betting you
would end up in a different place and
get different performance so the
property really has to do with whether
the network kind of gets knocked off
track by SGD noise in a sense and you
it's a good question that you and our
ICML reviewers asked about whether you
know instability is predictive of
generalization and the answer is for the
sparse sub networks it is and the reason
probably is that instability really
represents some proxy for whether the
network is getting knocked off course
and then getting stuck somewhere for the
dense networks though we hypothesize
that they just have so many parameters
that they're unlikely to get stuck
wherever whatever course they take
they're likely to keep on going until
they find a minimum that generalizes
well to say that you've gone to your
lottery ticket hypothesis where you say
you hypothesized maybe the training
process benefits from this over
parameterization and you came to the
sort of conclusion with your initial
evidence that no it actually doesn't
actually we don't even need this / / a
materialization for train
as long as we have the good initial
ization right and now it almost seems to
come back again to say actually in in
some cases in in bigger cases we do need
that initial over parameterization to
reach the stability regime so I think
that's right I think that you know this
is like like any good scientific process
you know there is you know we had our
original hypothesis we have kind of the
the counterpoint that you know maybe
this doesn't work on larger scale
networks and we have this nice synthesis
at the end where you know perhaps on
larger scale networks there's a period
where you may need the dense Network and
then after that you may be able to prune
once and then keep that sparsity for the
entire rest of the way and so you know
maybe at some high level and this is
pure speculation that maybe there is
kind of some Explorer exploit trade-off
going on here maybe during this initial
phase the network is exploring trying to
find kind of a groove in the
optimization landscape over which it can
you know make progress and then after
that point we could have pruned
now the one other caveat I want to throw
in there is these results are all
contingent on one particular strategy
for trying to find these lottery tickets
and it's not a very good strategy
there's no reason to believe that
pruning at the end should tell you very
much about what you could have pruned
early on so it's entirely possible that
you know some better strategy for
finding lottery tickets will mean that
we don't need this initial phase of
dense training this is you know we're
limited by the techniques we have to
explore this and I hope that folks come
up with better methodologies that are
algorithms for finding these lottery
tickets that would make a huge
difference I think that could completely
change these results
there's no sorry go ahead like Jonathan
said pivoting into better techniques for
finding these lottery tickets this
rewinding algorithm where you where you
do the iterative magnitude pruning and
then you retrain it but you just
retrained it by restoring the learning
rate I thought that was really
interesting that you have that like you
don't reset the weight but you reset the
learning rate can you tell me a little
bit more about how important it is to
have some kind of cyclical learning rate
then and like doesn't that add more
complexity with learning right now or
I'm just curious about like how you
figured out this learning rate could be
reset
so this is a this is a great question
about our recent I clear paper the first
author Alex Rando here's a student in
our lab you know worked really hard on
this for the past year and he got Norlin
I clear on this paper so the let me let
me kind of give some context for this
because it takes on a slightly different
problem than what we've been discussing
so the lottery ticket work is all about
trying to understand what's there a
sparse subnetwork early in training that
could have done the same work as the
full network could we have basically
replaced training the full network with
a smaller network the particular paper
you're talking about which is comparing
rewinding and fine-tuning and neural
network pruning is all about asking the
question well you know if we find a
lottery ticket we've also found a prune
Network because you know you just take
that lottery ticket train it to
completion and now you've got a prune to
neural network is this a good pruner all
network how does it compare
what are these sparsity as we get out of
the lottery ticket networks and how do
they compare to what we got from
state-of-the-art sparsity and so what we
did was we just tried taking the lottery
ticket algorithm and asking these Pru
networks that we get how do they do
compared to standard prune networks with
other techniques and the answer was
actually pretty good in fact about state
of the art and then we tried tweaking
one thing so in standard lottery ticket
you would take your network train it to
the end to prune it go back to the
beginning or go back early on and then
redo this whole process now if your goal
is just to get a small network at the
end you don't really care how you get
there maybe you should just keep the
weights you had at the end of training
maybe you shouldn't go back this is what
people typically do in pruning so the
only difference is you take the learning
rate from that you would have gotten
from rewinding but you don't bother to
reset the weights and it turns out that
this gets you even better performance in
fact this kind of we found for sparse
pruning matches state of the art across
a wide range of you know networks and
I'll and matches a bunch of
state-of-the-art techniques that are way
more complicated my hope for this is
that not that this is you know the
pruning algorithm that everybody will
use forever but that this is such a
simple baseline that you know if you
want to advertise a new pruning
algorithm you know beat this like put
this line on your paper and show that
your line is better like it would be
most exciting to me if in the next five
years I see our line get crushed by a
bunch of other lines because that would
suggest that we're making some progress
in pruning which is you know I'm not
sure we've really made that much
progress in the past 10 years
anyway that's a separate paper that we
worked out of the fall just quickly to
that point that you said about the
rewinding of the learning rate how'd you
so we kind of had an understanding of
what the weights might be good to be
rewound to a certain point but why would
the learning rate just rewinding the
learning rate like offer such a good
solution so let me let me take the
alternate perspective and ask what we
were doing before we proposed learning
rate rewinding which is that once you
prune the network you train it for a
little while this is called fine-tuning
at the lowest learning rate or at some
lower learning rate you had during the
training process and the I the kind of
intuition behind that is that maybe you
know you're already late in the training
process you're already close to the
optimum you just need to do a little bit
of extra training and you don't want to
rock the boat too much that was kind of
the intuition but I might ask you know
what's the justification for that
learning rate over any other learning
rate and so in some sense by going to
this what really is a cyclic learning
rate schedule where after we prune we
increased the learning rate back to a
high learning rate and then work our way
back down you know it's I have a lot of
speculation as to why that might work
but it's really pure speculation but by
that same token you know all we have to
support the fine-tuning process we did
before is also pure speculation so in
some sense this is an area where we
don't really have much to go on right
now and there's an opportunity to do
some really good science do you think
the the fact that you prune is
constraining your your function that you
represent so much that basically you can
now rock the boat more without going out
of this optimum you were so if you
basically leave out the the small
connection in the network those might
screw you up
but you only you only you remain you
only retain the large weights those were
the ones that basically led you to the
current optimum and that optimum is
probably pretty steep in those
directions therefore you might as well
jack up the learning rate a bit and you
probably won't leave it
that's one good hypothesis and it's not
a bad idea I think the the question in
my mind is always like I don't love to
speculate wildly unless I have an
experiment where I can validate that
speculation and you know when I do that
then I read a paper and so I'm trying to
think in my mind now about how
would evaluate this and one way to do
that would be actually to maybe take
some of the ideas from our linear mode
connectivity paper and combine them here
maybe you know see whether you leave the
optimum by by trying to linearly
interpolate between the result of doing
this doing different kinds of
fine-tuning and you know the network you
had at the end of training to see
whether maybe you leave the optimum or
maybe whether different learning rate
schedules have different results but the
you know if if training up this higher
learning rate doesn't leave the optimum
then you have to ask the question why
did it make a difference if you're kind
of in the same optimum then what was the
what was the point of of increasing the
learning rate and so I think there may
be more to it than that but we have a
few ideas that we're thinking about I
don't want to speculate too much because
I you know wild speculation must be
accompanied by experiments that can
evaluate that wild speculation and I
don't have an experiment yet is this
leads maybe so this leads into a
question that we got on reddit but I
think Connor you had something more
topical to say oh I'm sorry I just
wanted to backtrack one up quickly I
just want to get a better understanding
of so with linear mode connectivity it
looks to me we're training two copies of
the same Network and they're getting
different batches of data and that's how
we're doing the comparison could you
just explain a little further on how
we're describing them being connected
definitely that's a fantastic question
so the idea is that suppose we have two
neural networks and we want to compare
them somehow we want to understand kind
of how similar they are to each other
there are so many ways of doing this
there there's a method called CCA that
you know looks at looks at the
similarity the representations you can
look at which examples they classify the
same in which examples they classify
differently you could look at the the l2
distance between the parameterizations
and one way that we tried a bunch of
these and they're all you know buried in
the appendices of the paper but one way
that we found that kind of gave some
really clean results was asking are they
in the same optimum that is to say can
you take the representation of these two
networks and find a path between them
over which loss doesn't increase so can
you find some valley that connects these
networks and this has been done there
there are a couple of great papers from
that show that for in most cases on
standard neural networks you can
actually do this you can then all train
neural networks seem to be part of one
giant high dimensional Valley and you
can find relatively simple paths between
them but you can't find linear paths
between them and we ended up finding
that you know first for a specific for
the specific examples we looked at in
lottery ticket the presence of linear
paths seem to be very predictive of
whether these networks train to good
accuracy which may suggest that although
these networks are in some giant
connected optimum it may be that the the
linear connection suggests some kind of
greater degree of similarity or some
some you know better relationship or
some tighter relationship between the
networks then you would get with a
nonlinear path and so that's all it is
we're looking to see you know what
happens on the lost landscape as you go
from one representation to the other do
you encounter some big barrier which
would suggest that they're not linearly
connected Optima or or can you just go
along this flat path where all the
networks in between are kind of equally
good and we ended up finding that in a
lot of these lottery ticket situations
and we found a bunch of cases for
standard networks where this also
happens so the question the question we
got from reddit that is sort of relate
to what you were saying before from SB
sia paul is how do you go about research
in general and what are your approach
towards picking up research topics and
then pursue them in an interesting
matter of high level you talked a bunch
about oh we had this idea we had this
idea we had this idea as we all know
most ideas don't work out so how how
what's your process so if all my ideas
had worked out we'd be talking about 60
papers instead of you know four or five
papers so they in some sense you know
you fail a lot a lot of things don't
work I have tons of little manuscripts
that are sitting in my computer right
now of all sorts of things that I
thought might have been interesting that
completely failed you know there's a lot
of failure on the path to the couple of
lottery ticket papers we wrote and a lot
of things I've tried along the way that
didn't work even things if you look at
the earlier archived versions of a lot
of these papers you'll you'll see that I
love to encourage folks to go and look
at the archive v1 of a lottery ticket if
you want to see how the idea of
loved and how you know my maturity as a
researcher evolved that original paper
was pretty rough to be polite to my
former self and you know pretty terrible
if if you want to be direct about it but
in terms of you know how we pick ideas
in my mind you know the questions I'm
interested in are the scientific ones
how can we gain an understanding of how
of the phenomena that we see in neural
networks by doing scientific experiments
how can we design a good experiment that
will somehow evaluate a hypothesis as to
why something is happening so I like to
do this kind of empirical scientific
work beyond that I mean you know the
human condition of a PhD student is
learning how to do research how to ask
nebulous questions make them testable
evaluate get to an answer write a paper
iterate and in some sense that comes
from practice and experience and a lot
of a lot of things going wrong so what
Jonathan did you kind of discover this
like buy this lottery ticket hypothesis
was that kind of like an accidental
discovery while studying pruning like or
did you specifically that's kind of my
question it's like were you looking into
pruning and then this just came up and
you're like oh wow look at what I found
um kind of there's a much longer story
to how this happened but you know this
is my first deep learning project and
all that happened was you know I was
reading some papers on pruning and you
know because I was just trying to read
various papers on deep learning and
found pruning kind of interesting that
you know maybe there was hope for making
these networks simpler because you know
at that time I didn't have very many
resources I basically just had my laptop
because I wasn't doing deep learning
research and so personally I was kind of
it would have been great for me if these
networks could be made smaller and more
efficient because you know I wanted to
get to I want to get to join the party
and as a and I happen to you know ask a
professor at MIT a question about you
know why we can prune at the end but not
at the beginning which is a question
that get at it gets asked it a lot of
the standard pruning papers everybody
tends to cite and he gave some
high-level explanation that involved you
know maybe there's some exploration of
the lost landscape the network kind of
learns to memorize and then compresses
its representation I don't remember what
exactly it was but it was something
where I went you know how would I test
this and what are other possible
hypotheses for what's going on the
lottery ticket idea being one of the
hype
the Seas I kind of sat down at my laptop
coated up a really simple experiment on
a neural network with two hidden units
for X or you can see this in the
original v1 if you want to see it on
archive its public although thankfully
hard to find and you know it started
working I basically the initial
algorithm that you know is this
iterative magnitude pruning algorithm
today started working and I was like wow
this is kind of cool and then someone
said to me we'll have you tried
considering it on a real task and then I
had to go well what's a real task they
said well you should try em NIST I was
like what's em dist and you can look at
the versions of the papers and see this
repeated over and over and over again
for what see far what's ResNet what's
imagenet and this was really meant to be
my excuse to get to learn how to do deep
learning and learn a little tensor flow
and you know it happened to turn into a
very nice paper instead but that wasn't
necessarily the goal when things started
painful so just to kind of pull back
quickly so another kind of popular idea
that's been around is kind of the double
descent and kind of one of the things
that they extrapolate from there is
about the over parameterization is
necessary because there's noise in the
data set that kind of needs to be
memorized by the network to allow it to
kind of generalize to the rest how do
you think that plays into kind of the
lottery ticket hypothesis it's tricky to
say for starters you know I haven't
looked into the double descent
phenomenon two too closely beyond the
high-level idea so I don't want to you
know speak out of turn on that but I
would say that you know on all the
lottery ticket networks we look at we're
in the wildly over parameterised regime
these networks are kind of in the second
descent yeah that's so I'm not sure that
it has much to say about the first
descent and I'm not sure it has I'm not
sure how much I would draw connection to
the phenomenon in general beyond the
fact that you know maybe we don't need
quite as much over parameterization as
we think ok cool thank you
so I I wanted to just really quickly and
when I was making notes on your paper I
drew an optimization surface and what
you're saying in this linear mode paper
is that you can train for a little bit
then you can you can fork you can create
two networks and train them separately
and because of the randomness of SGD
they'll go to slightly different places
in the optimization surface and you are
saying that it's the it's the the loss
minimum that's important as opposed to
the structure of the network itself
because you're not necessarily saying
that the structure will be the same and
my intuition is it's the structure of
the network which gives a useful
inductive prior but is your hypothesis
that a similar position on the lost
surface so if you can linearly
interpolate between these two positions
then for all intents and purposes the
network gives the same useful inductive
prior ah it's it's hard to necessarily
distinguish between the structure and
the initialization that's one of the
biggest problems with lottery ticket is
it would be nice to say it's all about
the structure it's all about the
initialization and yet it's this nasty
combination of both I with respect to
what let me make sure I understand the
question so whether two networks if
they're if they have the linear mode
connectivity property they give the same
inductive fire or the network they
started with has the same kind of
inductive fire is that the right way to
think about it yes if you have two
positions with you know in different
places in the lost surface but they have
the same loss and maybe as a to
strengthen that statement they also have
a linear mode connectivity with with no
big you know peaks in the way does that
mean for all intents and purposes they
represent the same inductive prior about
the data um it depends on what you mean
by inductive prior about the data I
would in terms of what do you mean by
inductive prior about the data I want to
clarify that language okay so my
conception of the lottery ticket
hypothesis is that and what we really
want to find is a subnetwork with an
initialization which represents
something I mean an example of an
inductive prior might be a CNN for
example with which which understands as
if there's a there's a local
connectivity so so and in networks in
general with we're learning an inductive
prior which might increase our
generalization to new previously unseen
data or you know giving us some kind of
adaptivity to other similar tasks
I'm not sure that I would be able to
speak about the inductive prior of a
trained Network because in some sense
you know the network has already went
whatever inductive fire you had earlier
the network is in some sense fulfilled
but I would speak about the inductive
prior of the network where you've made
the two copies so wherever you began the
process that ended with linear mode
connectivity and to say that it had the
same inductive fire to evaluate that one
would want to look at the functional
similarity of the networks to see
whether you know they actually learned
the same thing and what we find this is
you know in the many pages of appendices
of the paper what we find is a
complicated story for the dense networks
they don't really become that much more
functionally similar once they achieve
once they get to a place where they'll
have linear mode connectivity for the
sparse networks however they become much
more functionally similar suggesting
that this linear mode connectivity is
kind of in some sense a stronger
property or stronger prior on the result
of the sparse networks but not
necessarily for the dense networks so
again there's this kind of the the
nature of how this linear mode
connectivity of the implications of this
linear mode connectivity for different
kinds of networks seems to be different
and in the sparse context it seems to
imply a lot more about the network than
it does in the dense context where
perhaps there's just a lot more
flexibility you know where the network
goes and what it learns Jonathan do you
think the inductive prior on these
sparse layers are similar to kind of how
the attention mechanism has sort of a
sparse connection with its input like
that's a big question the we don't know
why sparsity seems to show up in all of
these contexts I think would be the
right way of putting it one can
speculate and I've heard everyone from
you know grad students to Geoff Hinton
speculate about this and you know in in
a language context with attention being
sparse you know I would guess that you
know when you attend over a sentence not
every word is crucially important for
understanding or for you know improving
the representation of a particular word
and so perhaps you know sparsely in that
context to make sense for a linguistic
perspective I'm not a I'm not a linguist
though so don't don't take or take what
I say with a grain of salt when it comes
to sparsity in the neural networks
themselves or why
you know sparsity test seemed so natural
all I have is uninformed speculation
that I can't evaluate so I don't want to
say much more than that
but it seems interesting that sparsity
seems to show up in all these contexts
it's kind of unfortunate in a way
because we don't have any computational
platforms that train particularly well
let's sparsity at least that are
available as commodity platforms right
now some of the newer chips that
companies like Graf corn Cerebrus are
producing have sparsity as kind of a
first class primitive but GPUs and CPUs
don't but if but my my kind of research
hypothesis is that sparsity seems to be
natural to the representations neural
networks learned we can get rid of all
these extra connections when we prune
when we do lottery ticket it doesn't
seem to affect accuracy it doesn't seem
to affect a lot of other properties they
have a short workshop paper and
interpretability
and it doesn't seem to affect the
interpret ability of these lottery
ticket networks we're looking at a bunch
of other properties in our lab right now
and it just doesn't seem to be having
much of an impact which to me suggests
that maybe all this stuff we got rid of
really wasn't doing much to begin with
the network wasn't able to take
advantage of that and so perhaps you
know the representations the network's
seem to be learning are in some sense
sparse so on the on the side of this so
most of the gain is it really actualized
with the current hardware or it's like
we're waiting on the graph Corsair bus
seems like right now something we talked
about yesterday is that you Matt is like
you apply this one zero mask right to do
the pruning and so like does that
actually like make inference take longer
because you have to pass it through the
mask or and then I also think like is it
speed-up training because you can have
faster gradient computation because you
don't have to you know put the gradient
through as many weights but how much of
this gain is actualized in modern
hardware so I haven't tried to actualize
this gain I think would be the the
honest answer I've I'm frankly in it for
the science so to me it's just exciting
to understand can you make these things
things smaller and I let people who know
a lot more about hardware than me worry
about how to make these run fast but you
know having talked to people who know a
lot more about hardware than me what
they tell me is that actual izing the
games about sport the gains from
sparsity is rather hard you need to be
pretty sparse before you even hit the
break-even point of training the network
with the sparse representation and
depending on who you ask that could be
anywhere from 50% to 90% sparsity
at least on on commodity dense hardware
no thankfully and kind of looking toward
the future number one we have lots of
great platforms that are coming to
fruition now that do run well with
sparsity the first being CPUs the second
being you know all these cool new
platforms that are coming out from a lot
of the startups that are building deep
learning hardware that are placing bets
on the fact that you know sparsity will
be the future so you know I happen to
agree with their bets but also you know
we there's a spectrum of sparsity you
don't have to be either sparse or dense
and open AI it sounds like it's done a
lot of great work on block sparsity
where you can start to take advantage of
this because you have you know some
sparsity you have sparsely but at a
greater granularity you can do
structured sparsity where you prune
parts of the network to try to preserve
density and that doesn't get you to a
small of networks as you get from sparse
pruning in terms of parameter count but
in terms of real-world wall clock speed
up you can actually just make the tensor
smaller and get speed up that way and
you know there's a there's probably also
a compiler story here if can we find
ways to make sparsity or the sparsity we
find run faster and that's something
we're also looking at in our lab right
now so the answer is complicated but I
don't think as it's black and white as
you know sparse equals slow dense equals
fast and that's the end of the story at
least I hope not for my sick
excellent so one of the things you
alluded to is ok you're on mute Matt
sorry one of the things you alluded to
kind in the paper was well you didn't
experiment or you tried and used on
supervised learning and transfer the the
kind of sparse network to the supervised
setting and obviously it required a lot
more data do you feel that you could
generally achieve lottery tickets from
unsupervised settings that would
transfer well to there to say like image
net etc or do you feel like it really
has to be on the specific data set in
order for its bendy kind of be useful so
to answer that question I would actually
defer you to two different papers that
have been written by fantastic
colleagues at Facebook one paper that
was in NURBS this past year looks at
whether these lottery tickets transfer
between tasks at least to own image
tasks and the answer is yes if you find
one of these one image that it transfers
as well to places and see far 100 and
see far 10 we
the relatively little loss in accuracy
which suggests that you know these these
lottery tickets are kind of still
relatively general-purpose networks at
least within a family of tasks like you
know natural images which which also
suggests that although it may be
expensive to find these lottery ticket
networks if you have a situation where
you need to retrain a network often and
maybe there's some distribution shift
finding a lottery ticket once is
probably going to be good for quite a
while and I'd also defer your attention
to a second great paper from my
colleagues at Facebook on looking at
lottery tickets for self supervised and
unsupervised learning and the answer is
that yeah you do find a lottery tickets
in this setting as well so I and this is
surprising to me I would have thought
these would be wildly overfit to
whatever data set you end up having
because your training and pruning and
going back and training and pruning
again you're kind of overfitting both
the weights and the architecture but
that seems not to be the case which to
me is both surprising and really
exciting because it gives an application
to this work I think so very very
related to this is a a reddit question
that not wolfman's brother asks do
lottery tickets exist for all models
like Ganz V AES and neural not neural
network architectures like are n ends
and resonates do they exist for
reinforcement learning policies so are
they general enough so let me start by
saying that I would never make the claim
that they exist for all networks and the
reason why I say that is because I don't
like to make claims unless I can provide
some evidence the lottery ticket
hypothesis is a hypothesis because you
know no amount of evidence will ever
prove it true at least no amount of
empirical evidence will ever demonstrate
it to be true and when it comes to these
specific networks that are mentioned
here there's yet another paper from my
colleagues at Facebook that looked at
NLP and or that looked at transformers
and RL and found that lottery tickets
generally existed for that that was just
presented in AI clear on Tuesday in RI
clear paper we looked at our n ends and
found that you know it seems to work for
our n ends as well for Ganser VI use go
tried and let me know shoot me an email
if you find out I would love to - no
these are different kinds of tasks and
more complicated tasks and you know who
knows if they don't work that's
interesting and that it would be
interesting to understand why
they don't work and that would tell us a
lot more about the nature of neural
networks I love these situations where
things fail and you can find the exact
threshold where things fail because that
that gives you a great opportunity to do
some science so on the subject of like
finding lottery tickets in say a deeper
network do you suspect that it might not
exist at all or that it just takes more
rounds of the iterative pruning
algorithm to find them so when the
deeper networks if you mean add
initialization or do you mean in general
yeah so like the difference between
finding a lottery ticket and like a
ResNet 20 compared to like a super big
efficient is the difference that you
need to prune it more times um I
wouldn't necessarily say that I think
it's really even if you just do one shot
pruning so you just prune at the end and
go back you still find pretty decent
lottery tickets the reason why we do
things iteratively is just that you can
shave off a few more wait so it seems to
make the process work a little bit
better and so if you wanted the smallest
possible lottery ticket or this or the
smallest possible prude network in
general doing it iteratively tends to
work best but you know that's
computationally expensive and even if
you don't do it iteratively you still
find lottery tickets you just generally
can't get quite as small of a lottery
ticket that way so my takeaway was that
the one shot is way lagging behind the
iterative is that not true
it depends on the setting and it depends
on what you mean by way
so all these vary quite a bit depending
on the architecture the tasks everything
else and you know we tend to plot
everything at a logarithmic scale so
that you can see the detail at the
smaller sparse trees but it also kind of
exaggerates the differences in outcome
between say one-shot pruning and an
iterative pruning so it's worth I would
need to take a look at the graphs again
to look at that I haven't done a
thorough comparison of the two but in
our paper and I clear where we looked at
comparing rewinding and fine-tuning we
we did end up finding that you know
things worked for one shot they just
work a little bit better and if you want
to get state of the art you should use
iterative wanted to explore a little bit
on around domain adaptation and
adversarial examples and also
democratization you said something
really interesting about you know five
or ten minutes ago which was that you
were doing deep learning on your laptop
and
I think this represents the ultimate
catch-22 situation because we know that
you can create these wonderful pruned
lottery tickets but you still need to do
all of the training so so first of all
could you talk a little bit about some
of you know just in general that there
are other types of you know ways to
compress neural networks things like
quantization and distillation but you
did make an interesting comment in your
linear mode paper which is that
sub-networks found by AI MP with rewind
transfer between vision tasks better so
but because of that increase in domain
adaptation you're almost amortizing the
extra time that you spent for it you
know finding those lottery tickets in
the first place and as an addendum to
that does that have implications and in
terms of resisting adversarial examples
or does it make it more prone for
adversarial example so let me see there
are a lot of questions here with respect
to domain adaptation my guess is that
given that transfer learning seems to
work on these lottery tickets that you
know these should be good even given
that the domain of the data shifts a
little bit and I don't know how to
quantify a little bit but it seems like
at least within the family of natural
image tasks this seemed to work I'd be
curious to see in an NLP setting where
whether you know maybe you can get some
good transfer between like machine
translation and language modeling or
something like that that would be
interesting and that would tell us a lot
but even you know between language
modeling on one data set and language
modeling on one on another machine
translation on one language and another
language it would be interesting to see
you know someone work on that and it
would be cool to find out what would
happen I'd love to read that paper with
respect to adversarial robustness stay
tuned on that there have been a couple
papers that have looked at this I don't
think anyone's looked at it quite to the
level of depth and rigor I'd like so
stay tuned keep an eye on archived so um
not a question from Reddit Nemo asks
suppose you tried to construct a lottery
ticket by taking all the weights that
were not part of a winning ticket and
Retraining from those will that model
the unable to learn the task or might
there be another winning ticket hiding
among them or one one that wasn't
originally used so this is the most
common question I get by people who read
the original paper and I I hope that by
answering it here in a public forum I
can answer it once and for all
the challenge in doing this experiment
is let's take the amnesty example so
suppose that we find a winning ticket on
immunised it's going to be about 3% of
the original size of the network so that
means that if you remove it you've still
got 97% of the weights left and so my
guess is that if you were to train those
97% of weights you'll get to the same
accuracy as you got with a hundred
percent of weights because you've barely
proven the network at all you could
randomly proven by three percent it
wouldn't affect it and then you could go
and find another lottery ticket that's
mutually exclusive with the first you
still have 94 percent of the weights and
you could probably iterate this for a
very long time probably you know you
could you could probably this way find
you know 10 15 lottery tickets like this
maybe more that are all mutually
exclusive and still leave you with the
remaining kind of residual that is
capable of training to full accuracy so
the challenge with this experiment is
that the lottery tickets are small which
is great but it means that whatever is
left is large enough that you know I'm
sure there's another lottery ticket in
there and another lottery ticket in
there and so on and so on and so on so
it's a it's a it's an interesting idea
in principle but once you kind of look
at the sizes of things you've still got
so much over parameterisation left that
I think you you just find more lottery
tickets you can even probably I'm
guessing swap out one weight from a
lottery ticket with another weight and
it wouldn't matter or swap out a handful
of weights and so combinatorially the
number of lottery tickets is massive and
we're just finding one it's also like
what would be the application of that I
mean it if there were you know if if a
lottery ticket were really big like if
it were half the network it would be
interesting to see what would happen to
the other half the network but we know
so if it's kind of it's a size issue
more than anything else that you know if
only we it would be nice to compare the
the residual here if if the sizes were
commensurate and I think that's the
intuition a lot of people have when they
think about this without you know
looking too hard at the numbers it's
only when you really dig into the
numbers that you
that this idea becomes a little bit less
interesting I think all right next
question
x1x asks what are the art what are your
views on the recent paper of malakut all
aware they prove the strong lottery
ticket hypothesis and maybe you can
formulate that hypothesis in your words
so I don't want to go too far in trying
to describe this paper because I will
start by saying I'm an empiricist
because I'm bad at math and so reading
theory papers is a challenge for me and
for anyone else out there who finds
machine learning theory papers
challenging please know that you have a
friend and compete reott in that fact so
I haven't AI haven't had time to dig
into this paper too deeply and be I
think the amount of time it would take
me to fully understand this paper would
be you know longer than it would take me
to write another paper but at a high
level there have been a few works that
have looked at not well the original
lottery ticket idea is all about finding
a sparse network that optimizes well and
if I recall correctly if I understood at
least the the setup of the proving the
lottery ticket hypothesis paper this is
looking at a randomly initialized sub
Network and how accurate this would be
compared to or whether there exists a
randomly initialized sub network that
could be as accurate as a dense network
and so the optimization process is not
taken into account here and there's some
other work that looks on this there's a
paper that looks at can you find high
accuracy networks that are just frozen
if they're random initializations by by
finding a good pruning mask and I think
this is an interesting set of problems
it's definitely not the original lottery
ticket setting as we envisioned it so
you know I don't own the brand and
people are welcome to use the term
lottery ticket or the metaphor the
lottery however they like but I don't
think it's the same problem that I'm
looking at well I I have a bit of a I
have a bit of an issue with papers like
this that try to to prove these kinds of
things because if I read the abstract
right now part of it is showing that for
every bounded distribution every target
network with bounded waits a
sufficiently over parameterised neural
network with random weights contains a
sub network with roughly the same
accuracy so it turns out when you read
these theorems often times you'll find
that this sufficient over
parameterization is more than atoms in
the
universe or something like this so
basically you'll have every single
combinatorial combination of whatever
you can think of as a sub Network
somewhere in there and it becomes rather
unsurprising that there exists something
good in there do you do do you know of
any work that is really convincing you
in that regard where someone is more
formal than maybe you would do research
so it's I don't want to speak too much
to theoretical machine learning in
general if your theory of deep learning
in general simply because in a lot of
senses it's it's kind of a I almost see
it as a separate field from what I work
in given that the kinds of empirical
networks we look at are you know big
they're complicated they're on real data
with you know batch norm and residual
connections and weight decay and all
sorts of other fancy heuristics we've
thrown in to make them work properly and
a lot of the models that folks look at
in in these papers are kind of of a
different nature they're infinitely wide
or they're single layer with the second
layer frozen or you know the notion of
the data isn't really you know how do
you formalize imagenet in a mathematical
way that you can do proofs about it so
in that sense I don't want to comment
too much because I'm not the expert here
so I can't really say you know is that a
good bound is this thing too big is this
realistic or unrealistic I think I find
theory work valuable because it it gives
me new ideas and it gives me new
insights that I may not have been able
to find empirically gives me new things
to try the you know a lot of the a lot
of the ideas for a lottery ticket have
come from my co-author Karolina
who you know does theoretical machine
learning and she's had a lot of great
insights from that background but in
terms of my ability to distinguish you
know which which ideas from theory are
you know perhaps more applicable and
less applicable I'm as ignorant as
anyone on that so it's not my place to
comment visiting a little bit on the
training bachelor-man only bastard on
paper could you tell me like a bit about
what inspired those experiments so this
is this is an interesting paper to give
a quick summary of it this is asking the
question you know batch norm normalizes
the activations coming out of a
particular unit or a particular
convolution
but it also multiplies them by a
trainable scale parameter and adds a
trainable bias parameter so every time
you use batch norm you're introducing
two new trainable parameters per feature
and they're often neglected and they're
often so neglected that when I was
trying to run a completely different
experiment I wanted to freeze the
weights in the network and I forgot to
freeze the batch norm weights because I
forgot they existed and the network was
still training to good accuracy I didn't
understand what in the world was going
on or why performance was you know this
network shouldn't have done anything and
yet it was training to decent accuracy
and finally someone said well you know
did you remember to freeze the bat
remember that storm has parameters the
paper was born so I think it's a and and
this is the one case where I made a
horrible mistake and it turned into
something good I don't think that's
happened to be otherwise usually I make
horrible mistakes and just waste a month
of time and that happens a lot
that's why pH D is five years but you
know in this case we happen to find that
actually if you just train these
parameters you can get to surprisingly
good accuracy not great accuracy not
state-of-the-art accuracy but if you
were to pull a random sample of you know
a thousand machine learning researchers
and ask them the accuracy they would
think you would get this would be much
better and a lot of people would think
it would just be random accuracy so
that's interesting in the one sense it
draws attention to these parameters
which I think we often forget and a lot
of work on analysis of batch norm
they're left out they're just they're
left out of the analysis because they
complicate things and you know I forgot
they existed or never knew they existed
so we should know and you know there
there are some other possible
applications but I'd have to stretch to
do that it's kind of a it's a fun idea
and an interesting piece of science I
think more than anything else is it
quick because because like could you
imagine it being useful to have just an
enormous randomly way to network and
then only train the bass-drum parameters
like is there a potential application
that you see with that one could imagine
it there's a whole literature on what's
called reservoir computing where all you
do is you create random features and
then you learn a linear classifier on
top of that so there's a long legacy in
the literature of doing things like this
and it it seems to work surprisingly
well again surprisingly well like
sometimes as well as learning features
even
one could imagine this the challenge
comes down to performance and again I'm
not an expert on you know making things
run on the hardware but you still have
to back prop through most of the network
to update these bachelor in parameters I
have seen empirically I've seen some
wall clock time speed-up when you're
only training the batch alarm parameters
so maybe there there are some ways to
take advantage of this maybe just you
know memory accesses or again really I'm
talking about of turn if I say much
about how an actual computer works but
you know there is some speed-up and I
can imagine some application there but
this is really where it have to defer to
folks who have more expertise than I do
so I've got a question about the state
of machine learning in general it's
almost depressing in a way that the
whole lottery ticket hypothesis and the
word lottery seems to have these
connotations that it's only by random
chance that we get anywhere at all and
if you look at an even evolution for
example it's this process of trying many
many random things and it seems perverse
it seems like we're barking up the wrong
tree we should be doing something far
more intelligent in order to do learning
and Francois Chilean in his measuring
intelligence paper says that we need to
take a step away from you know having
these closed domain algorithms and
moving more towards having a focus on
you know the unknown unknowns and
adaptability and an open endedness and
so on so do you think that we're stuck
in a local minimum in the machine
learning world not really I mean that
when it comes to all of these questions
I mean the first question I ask is what
is our goal as a community and if you
were to ask that to every individual
researcher you would hear you know a
bunch of individual answers none of
which match each other even for a lot of
folks who are in the sparsity space with
me that's a very narrow space all of our
goals are completely different some
folks want performance some folks want
you know like me I'm interested in the
science as far as do you have this to be
a good way of getting at that so you
know I'm not a big believer in the fact
that you know we should be we should be
aiming for these general intelligence
robots I think that's something that you
know it's interesting to hear people who
don't you know people like Bill Gates or
Elon Musk talked about this people who
have never trained to neural network in
their lives but you know as far as I'm
concerned deep learning is doing great
stuff I mean it's
driving cars it's you know winning at
whatever video game it was I don't
really game but it's you know it seems
to be you know it want it go in it won
that what's Starcraft
I think that was the one so you know
it's it's doing good stuff it's been a
huge advance so you know we should be
thrilled that you know companies that do
AI are actually making money which is a
relatively new phenomenon given all the
past di winters with respect to you know
whether we should you know make some big
change in our approach to the field it
depends on your goal it depends on what
you're trying to achieve and you know
it's easy to say that in a lot of senses
if you can tell me the algorithm that we
should be using or you can tell me how
to actually go about doing this you know
go take your Turing award go you know go
enjoy completely changing the field
there's a reason this doesn't happen
very often so we have something that
works really well we have something to
build on here as a researcher I'd like
to stay productive and this is a place
where I can you know make meaningful
progress right now but you know if we
want to dump this and go to something
else there are a lot of great
researchers out there and there's not a
lot of work to do there because we don't
even know where to begin yet really do
that's a really interesting response but
I suppose if I was being if I was
playing devil's advocate and big a bit
cynical though there is this question of
what is it that you know these deep
learning algorithms what are they doing
and you can argue with this double
descent thing that maybe there is a
phase change and maybe as we train on
larger models with larger amounts of
data maybe they really are generalizing
in a meaningful way but if you were
being cynical you could argue that they
are just kind of they're just memorizing
everything and you know it's almost that
there's there's a gap between the
perception of what these models do and
the reality I don't know whether you
want to take that or we've got a reddit
question let me let me take that very
briefly suppose they are working just
based on a lot of memorization I mean
they seem to be working pretty well
that's I think the bottom line is what
are the results are they you know
generating meaningful text are they able
to drive a car relatively safely given
other constraints are they able to you
to do your image recognition tasks or
save somebody some work and the answer
seems to be in a lot of settings yes and
a lot of settings the answer is
definitely not and in those settings
we've we could desperately use something
better but to take your question and
turn it the other way you know if
lottery ticket is showing that these
networks are way bigger than they have
to be then that means we have a lot of
headroom left to push this this set of
ideas further we have a lot of headroom
left to make the most of the parameters
we have available you know where we
don't know what we're doing when it
comes to neural networks we don't know
how they work imagine what we can do if
we understand how they work so to be the
optimist here you know perhaps we're
merely scratching the surface of what
this particular set of algorithms can
achieve or perhaps you know we can solve
a lot of these problems given time to
actually do that science on the other
hand of course you know neural networks
may be the flavor of the decade and we
should have some new things coming down
the pike but doing that kind of work is
hard high risk very low reward and you
know speaking personally as someone who
wants to publish some paper so he can
get his PhD and move on with life you
know doing that kind of work is not
conducive to my ability to graduate to
be honest it's you know the academic
incentive structure is not such that if
I spend two decades working on a series
of ideas that don't work out I'm gonna
get rewarded for that
in some sense you know the the pioneers
of neural networks took some very big
risks to continue to advocate for this
technology for as long as they did and
those risks worked out but I kind of
wonder how many folks have done this for
similar ideas where the risks have never
worked out so it's it takes some people
who are willing to put their careers on
the line for this kind of thing to
happen absolutely ok well let's go to
another question from red X here's as an
aside I'm super excited we've got so
much buzz around this conversation today
we've been outvoted nearly a hundred
times on Reddit which is wonderful
so glockenspiel cello and whether you've
done any simple calculations about the
probability and the combinatorics of
lottery tickets and one of the takeaways
from the uber study which we haven't
spoken about yet seems to be that if you
believe their results that the sign of
the weights at initialization is the
most important characteristic of the
ticket
if you buy this model it would be
relatively simple to ask theoretical
questions of the form
what percentage of initializations have
ticket X as a subnetwork and how many
equivalent tickets are in the network
initialization and what is the
dependence of this probability on depth
and width etc and you know these various
saying is that a direction that you've
considered at all so this is let me I
have three or four different comments to
make about this when starting with you
know our friend glockenspiel cello we
don't know whether it's a he or she and
you know and you know I say that
jokingly but I also do say that
seriously you know we are not a very
diverse community and you know we we
should not assume that everybody who's
asking you a question on reddit is male
not to call you out or anything but to
take the opportunity to just you know
point that out because it's a you know
making those assumptions as part of the
reason why this community is less
welcoming to deploy identifies women but
to get to the actual question here the
component orcs kill you very quickly
what I would love to do is take a
lottery ticket and try it on you know
ten billion initializations and even
then I still wouldn't be I just be
scratching the surface of this massive
distribution of initializations or I'd
love to randomly sample 10 billion
lottery tickets from a network I've
tried on the order of 10,000 and still
haven't found one that works well by
randomly sampling which suggests that
you know whatever this distribution is
it is very unlikely to find a lottery
ticket so to try out the combinatorics
you have to do a lot of sampling or find
some clever way to do it and you know
maybe finding clusters of lottery
tickets or something like that and any
of these are very hard given that the
only lottery tickets we know how to find
are from one very specific probably bad
algorithm with respect to the uber paper
the science observation would in some
sense make this easier because it would
turn it into a combinatorial problem but
the fact remains that it's still the the
combinatorics of these sub networks are
just a mind-boggling even trying to
write down what the calculation would be
what a good sub Network looks like or
what a valid sub network looks like has
kept me occupied so we have some
thoughts along these lines we have some
ideas we're planning to try soon along
this but it is a very hard problem
because those combinatorics just
absolutely kill you even on the smallest
neural networks well there's not really
it's really exciting and sort of one
more thing that we wanted to discuss is
like we talked about the super
intelligent robots Elon Musk's style and
then I think everybody in machine
learning is familiar with you know
caution around it especially the GPT
two-stage release height machine and so
could you tell us a bit about Tech
policy I know it seems like most people
you know just kind of focus on what they
know and I don't imagine too many
machine learning people you know know
enough about what is happening with tech
policy and relating definitely so let me
briefly tell you what tech policy is a
little bit about what I do and kind of
you know what you should know if you're
you know the two seconds on that policy
is you know the idea of you know
creating law govern governance
structures kind of you know plans for
how we should handle these issues or
manage the consequences of these issues
these issues could be you know anything
from health care to you know the economy
to defense and in this case it's AI and
the effects on society so I have this
whole other life where I work in policy
kind of I moonlight sometimes as a law
professor at Georgetown where I've you
know teach students there I work with
journalists work with policy makers been
working with the OECD which is kind of a
UN style International Organization
trying to be kind of the voice of
technical expertise and a lot of these
conversations I think we all kind of
complain in the back of our minds that
you know these darned politicians they
don't you know they're all old they
don't know about computers they don't
know how technology works and it's easy
to complain it's hard to actually help
it's it's a lot harder to actually take
some action and make yourself useful in
that and it's hard for many reasons it's
hard because first of all you know you
have to actually be willing to help
solve a problem instead of just
complaining about it but more than that
it's hard because a lot of policy
revolves around trust revolves around
building relationships and revolves
around putting your ego aside I think in
the in computer science and especially
in AI we like to think that we know
better than everyone else we could
disrupt your industry we can reinvent
what you were doing in this really
labor-intensive way with an algorithm we
can to replace your worker with a I and
this hubris leads us to believe that
can reinvent the wheel on anything and
do it better than the experts you know
when it comes to say fairness or you
know law these are issues where you know
it turns out there's some pretty well
trained experts who have been studying
this question for a thousand years if
not more perhaps we should listen to
them and so we have to put aside our
opinions and do a lot of listening which
seems to be pretty hard for some folks
in the machine learning community right
now and that's what it takes just to get
in the door but to actually make an
impact you have to learn the language of
policy but the reward is you know in a
lot of these conversations there often
isn't a technical expert in the room and
if you're willing to go through all
those steps you can be that technical
expert and in doing so make the policy
better solve the problems that you spent
a lot of time on Twitter complaining
about so I think this is a huge issue
we're creating technology it's risky
it's dangerous we're not taking the
proper precautions when we let it out we
think that it's somebody else's problem
to deal with the consequences can you
bring this to life a little bit so
you're talking about policy so give me
an example of where could we have the
most impact because just based on what
you're saying at the end there it seemed
like you were talking about some of the
the ethical problems with AI such as
fairness and and and bias and
discrimination and so on are you talking
far more generally than that I'm talking
far more generally than that I think
anything that we put out into the world
whether it's AI or otherwise any
technical system you know has societal
consequences you can look at you know
the fake news issue you can look at you
know the the whole filter bubble
question you can look at every time that
a major company has put out a product
they've had to retract because it had
some huge privacy violation think google
buzz if anybody remembers back that long
I was in high school back then but it
was a big deal and then it disappeared
all of a sudden and turns out the
federal government shut it had Google
basically shut it down but in AI in
particular where we are making decisions
based on data we don't understand how
those decisions work we don't understand
the heuristics the biases the
memorization that's going into these
decisions and these decisions are having
real effects on real people's lives we
can take credit scoring a lot of
companies are now using neural networks
to do credit scoring that's whether
somebody can buy a house get a loan buy
a car go on with their life and you're
putting it in the hands of an algorithm
where you don't know what it does or
facial recognition that a lot of police
departments are using
I've worked on extensively but a police
department is using this to figure out
who they should you know add to the list
of suspects who they should investigate
you're putting people's life and liberty
into the hands of this crappy neural
network that you trained on a data set
of celebrities who are all white what
are you doing
think about it and on the other hand
from the policy side how do we regulate
this how do we make sure that your
stupid algorithm that you trained in
your basement and sold to your local
police department that doesn't happen or
that algorithm that's verified to make
sure it's actually good these are you
know these aren't small questions these
are again people's lives and people's
freedom are in the hands of you know
some quick decision you made about how
you were doing data augmentation or what
data set you were using think about it
think before you act I mean come on do
you see a fundamental conflict though
let's say between I mean machine
learning is is so fascinating but it the
machine learning models are
fundamentally designed to discriminate
and politically there is a kind of
dichotomy between the quality of
opportunity and the quality of outcome
so did deed are you fundamentally
conflicted in this regard or do you
think that there is a clear right ahead
no I think I mean look at any
application or any application of
decision making in society let's take
car insurance in the United States you
know this is a place where you're trying
to guess who is most likely to get an
accident and you know assess them a
certain insurance cost to make up for
the fact they're going to crash their
car with a certain likelihood you're
allowed to charge men more than women
and you know as a as a teenage boy I was
charged a lot more than my older sister
was for car insurance when I learned how
to drive because teenage boys tend to
get a lot more accidents and that's
legally allowed discrimination if you
were to do the same thing for hiring or
housing or anything else you're not
allowed to discriminate but in credit
scoring in many cases we are allowed to
discriminate between people who are more
creditworthy and less creditworthy you
just can't do it based on race and you
shouldn't you know this hopefully race
should not be correlated with your
credit decisions so we choose what we
allow and don't allow you to
discriminate by otherwise you know if
you don't discriminate you're not making
a decision so but there is a bit of a
moral minefield and it was great that
you brought up the car
surance one or the the great thing about
the car insurance example is it doesn't
touch any of the immutable
characteristics like race and gender and
so on but sorry gender is not immutable
I got that young males who have lots of
testosterone will drive more
aggressively and they'll get into lots
of accidents and you could argue that
that's fair or you just argued that it
was unfair
so did and is that different or does
does that kind of moral problem
generalize to the rest of policy oh this
is a this is a huge moral problem
throughout policy and these are moral
problems we've been grappling with for
centuries this isn't you know a new
problem because AI or computers have
come around this has been a question
about credit scoring for decades and we
have you know in the u.s. we have laws
around Fair Credit to decide what you
can't discriminate based on and what you
can't and these are questions we have to
adjudicate as a society through you know
through our societal discussions through
the policy process through the lawmaking
process and so these are decisions that
are being made in specific domains
constantly and you know these are tricky
questions the whole issue of affirmative
action in college admissions is that
unfair is that fair you know the this
has been debated since affirmative
action was you know come up with as a
concept and it you know it's been
working its way through the court
systems in the u.s. in recent years yet
again so these are questions to which we
don't necessarily know the answers but
they're questions when we do machine
learning we should think about and we
should ask the experts ask the people
who have actually thought about this
don't go and try to you know decide for
yourself what you think is or isn't fair
go talk to people who actually think
about this and understand the historical
context in which you are trying to
develop this algorithm I guess the the
issue that comes in new with AI and
machine learning is when you say
something like you're not you're not
allowed to discriminate based on race
the you can't tell that to the a
algorithm right there needs to be a
process to distill what you mean by that
into into an a algorithm so I appreciate
that that you and other people are
actually looking into this because that
that is it like an intersection of
ethics and machine
that is probably inaccessible to most
people of both regions but I would
actually if I can make one work one
comment on what you've just said - you
can't tell but you can test yeah you can
test like crazy okay is your facial
recognition algorithm biased well let's
run it through a bunch of data that's
actually what the US government does for
a lot of these algorithms these days is
you can submit it to the government and
they'll evaluate it on millions of
photos that the State Department has
collected to see you know what you're
you know whether you have biases based
on nation of origin which in a lot of
cases correlates with race and with
respect to you know not not having
mutual understanding of these questions
it's not that hard to understand these
questions I think we just have to be
willing to put aside our hubris and so I
challenge anyone who's listening to you
know go learn about these issues and all
their complexity and just keep that in
the back your mind is there a difference
between the car insurance one because
it's varied because even if you test it
afterwards and even in the UK we have a
quality legislation you're not allowed
to discriminate on gender but it's still
more expensive to get car insurance as a
man because every other field in their
model is a proxy for gender just the
type of car and that you know how
expensive the car is and so on and so
but there's a difference because you
gave the example of well a facial
recognition model shouldn't be racist
and we should check for that well of
course that the car insurance model will
always be biased
that's correct oh this is where I think
we have to we have to do the best we can
it's really when it comes down to and
you know there there are trade-offs here
that have to be adjudicated by a
regulatory agency to an extent can you
be biased on the basis of this other
information do we and this gets into I
think a lot of the fantastic work going
on to machine learning and fairness
right now where folks are trying to come
up with different definitions of
fairness that make these trade-offs
explicit so that policymakers have a
more concrete language in which to
specify what isn't isn't acceptable
these are questions that are going to
get adjudicated by the policy process
but I think the important part is
they're going to get adjudicated by the
policy process they should not be
getting adjudicated by us the people who
are making the algorithms who don't
necessarily have the domain expertise
or who
shouldn't be speaking on behalf of
society as a whole the way the policy
process in its idealized form does so to
to maybe because we've gone off a bit
from the lottery ticket I bought this
thanks for all that work to come back
maybe this my my last question and
already in advance I have to say to
everyone on ready to ask the question
thank you very much
we obviously don't have the capacity to
go through all of them but thanks and
sorry if yours wasn't part so my last
question would be to go back to research
and as we all know science is different
from research science is our ideal
process and the questions we ask and so
on
and research is I'm a PhD student and I
have to put out papers and I have to do
things right and so if you if you think
back maybe young PhD researcher maybe
not too many resources do you have like
a list of here are the top three things
that you know you should pay attention
to to to be successful in the research
world like here oh here's the here's the
really important things for you to not
be completely frustrated and drop out of
the field ah I'd be a hypocrite if I
were to say very much on this about
three weeks before the initial lottery
ticket results came in I was on the
phone with a with a mentor of mine
asking whether I should drop out of my
PhD so and you know PhDs are hard and
there are a lot of moments where you
know I've thought about leaving the what
I always told myself was you know the
only way that I'm going to be able to
make this 5-year commitment and get
through it is if I remind myself that I
can leave at any time and you know no
harm no foul so it's this is hard stuff
getting started is tough working with
limited resources is impossibly
difficult and you know I I have very
painful memories of a lot of moments
during my PhD where things weren't
working I felt like I had no direct
and the answer is in a lot of ways to
keep digging I think that has happened
for me and as happens for many people
you know our research direction comes
unexpectedly when you go down some
rabbit hole and never come back out and
in this case it was you know let me try
this small pruning experiment and go
down this rabbit hole and see what
happens there were a lot of failed
research efforts of all sorts of kinds
before that I mean my my wonderful
adviser Michael carbon he's my fourth
adviser during my PhD and so there's
been a long road of failure prior to
this project and after this project and
you know continuing to persist and
continuing to explore and try to ask
interesting questions and evaluate them
with whatever resources you have I found
that when I had interesting results it
earned me the ability to get better
resources by you know showing someone
who had some credits to give away or who
had a few dollars to spend or who had a
couple of GPUs they could let me borrow
and the original lottery ticket paper
was written in that way with borrowed
GPUs and you know a lot of a lot of
struggle to get things to run at the
scale that I had available so you know
research is really hard and I wish I
could give advice that would you know
make it all easier I can give empathy
which is the you know I've been there
and I continue to be there every single
day so Jonathan what are you reading at
the moment if you were to give us your
information diet and tell us about its
velocity and diversity and various
sources and I'd be fascinated to note um
I mean I tend to I read fewer papers
than I'd like to read the reason being
that you know if you tried to read all
the papers you'd never do any research
and so there's a trade-off there and I
feel like once I've gotten a good
research direction it's important for
you to read papers that are kind of
relevant and in that narrow area and
then read a smattering of papers that
people find interesting beyond that area
but it is hard to curate and figure out
what papers you should be reading what
papers you shouldn't and generally when
I go into a new problem I find one
paper that everybody seems to be talking
about and then read everything that
cites it and everything that it's cited
and kind of do a breadth-first search
outwards like that and it's generally a
good way to understand what the area is
what the questions are what the
conversation is looked like and from
there you can you can orient yourself
but I don't think machine learning is
you know I don't think it's really one
field anymore even deep learning is one
field anymore so you know I haven't read
really any papers about Gans because
it's not something that I study very
closely I don't know a lot about
reinforcement learning because it's not
something that I study closely and if I
were to try to keep up with all those
fields I wouldn't have time to keep up
with my research or the things that are
most relevant to the problems I'm most
interested in right now if I wanted to
pivot at some point I'd read a bunch of
papers on that topic and try to get up
to speed but I think the you know I read
papers I read abstracts a lot of the
time even if I don't read the paper and
I asked my friends what they're reading
and we we share and we we dig into these
kinds of things I participate in reading
groups but it's I think it's really
challenging to have a good information
diet and it always feels like you're
you're on this treadmill where you can
never read enough or never read
everything and next week there's going
to be another big paper that may change
the game so I think even you found
during this call
I haven't read everything there used to
read related to lottery ticket because
you know there's so much to read and
understanding all of that would require
you know building a bunch of background
in theory that I may not necessarily
have or may not come easily to me so I
don't know if that really answers the
question effectively but for all those
folks you feel a little overwhelmed by
this I empathize it's a challenge for me
every single day no it's absolutely fine
Jonathan and I was sorry I was related
that's absolutely great Jonathan I mean
just just to finish off I mean first of
all that this has been so wonderful
thank you so much but just as as a
finishing college service really where
do you see yourself in five years time
and if you could go back to the younger
Jonathan what advice would you give
yourself so I I didn't which Jonathan
were you talking about the second half
of your question I didn't quite catch
that I'm sorry if you could go back in
time and give you a younger self advice
what would you say
let me see so for the where do I see
myself in five years gosh I hope I'm
still doing interesting scientific
research on deep learning or whatever
whatever may come next or whatever we
find to be exciting at that point the
field moves fast and I'm under no
pretenses that deep learning is
something that you know will necessarily
stay on the test of time especially that
a lot of ridiculous data the test of
time I like to say that you know if
we're still talking about lottery ticket
in five years that's a really bad sign
for the field because we haven't made
the progress to understand to gain some
better understanding so I hope this is a
paper that is long forgotten because
we've you know we as a field have made
further progress in understanding what's
going on and I hope to be a part of that
as to where and when and how you know
I'll hopefully be on the job market next
year so you know you want to hire me
please let me know it sounds like the
economy's gonna be rough so I'd love to
have a job but all said and done so I'll
make that shoutout right now as to you
know pass to me I always wish I could
say to pass me take more math classes I
you know I'm I'm taking a lot of
hardcore math classes now late in my PhD
because you know you can never have
enough math and it always gives you new
insights I would say be patient because
a lot of things take a long time to
develop
and research especially you fail a lot
before you ever succeed once and then
you fail a lot more before you ever
succeed again you know don't go to that
one soccer game where you had the
concussion otherwise you know it's the
last thing I would say is be open-minded
to lots of different fields and lots of
different opportunities deep learning
I've only been doing deep learning
I hit my two-year anniversary last month
I haven't been doing this very long
before that I was trying to be a
cryptographer before that I was trying
to be a computer security person before
that I was trying to do law I was
teaching at a law school for a year
before that I was doing programming
language theory before that I was doing
distributed systems you know it I would
never have thought that going to a law
school to teach for a year would lead me
to do deep learning research and end up
writing the lottery ticket paper so you
know it's a PhD and a research
not a straight path to end enjoy the
journey absolutely well Jonathan and I
know I can speak for many people by
saying that your work has been a huge
inspiration so just keep doing what
you're doing and thank you so much for
coming on the channel and we'll see you
soon I hope
thank you so much for having me thank
you thanks Jonathan
thanks Nathan thank you